>> HISTORY UNFOLDING AT THE
U.S. CAPITAL TODAY WITH THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE'S
ANNOUNCEMENT OF FOUR CRIMINAL
REFERRALS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THE PANEL ARGUING THAT TRUMP
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO SERVE IN A
POSITION OF AUTHORITY AGAIN.
BUT IN A NUCLEAR, PLAYED BY THE
COMMITTEE, TRUMP'S LONGTIME
AIDE AND CONFIDANT, BEAU PICKS,
MADE IT --
PRIMARY GOAL HAS BEEN ALWAYS
BEEN WINNING.
AT THE EXPENSE OF ANYTHING
ELSE.
LISTEN TO HER DESCRIBE A
CONVERSATION SHE --
VOTER FRAUD.
>> THERE WAS EVIDENCE OF FRAUD
ON A SCALE THAT WOULD HAVE
IMPACTED THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
AND I WAS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED THAT WE WERE DAMAGING
WE WERE DAMAGING HIS LEGACY.
>> IN, A RESPONSE TO WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED?
>> HE SAID SOMETHING ALONG THE
LINES I HAVE, NOBODY WILL CARE
ABOUT MY LEGACY IF I LOSE.
SO, THAT WON'T MATTER.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS IS
WINNING.
>> ALL, RIGHT TO PUT SOME
PERSPECTIVE IN CONTEXT.
WITH OUR TEAM OF VETERANS FROM
THE WATERGATE HERE UP,
LEGENDARY JOURNALIST BOB
WOODWARD AND CARL BERNSTEIN,
AND NIXON COUNSEL JOHN DEAN.
JOHN, YOU KNOW SHE SAID ALL HE
CARED ABOUT WAS WINNING.
AND IF HE DIDN'T WIN, HE'D HAVE
NO LEGACY.
OF COURSE NOW HE DOES HAVE A
LEGACY.
SO WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU THE
MOST, FROM WHAT SHE SAID AND
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED TODAY?
>> FROM WHAT SHE SAID, IS THAT
HE'S GONNA HAVE A WRONG LEGACY.
THE LEGACY OF A LOSER.
AND THAT'S NOT A LEGACY HE CAN
--
LET'S DO IT OUT TO ME, WAS AT
THE VERY BEGINNING, THE
CHAIRMAN AND A PASSING REMARK
SAID, WE'RE SENDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS A
ROADMAP, WELL THAT CLICKED
RIGHT AWAY.
DURING WATERGATE, IT WAS JUST A
REVERSE.
THERE WAS A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
SENT TO CONGRESS A ROADMAP.
SO, THAT'S THE WAY THEY
ENVISION THIS DOCUMENT.
AND THIS MATERIAL BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN HERE MUCH LONGER
THAN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING.
SO, THEY'RE QUITE FAMILIAR WITH
WHERE THESE ROADS GO.
>> WITH WHERE THEY GO, AND ALL
THE TRANSCRIPTS, BACK UP,
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVEN'T --
YET.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FROM WHAT
YOU'VE NOW SEEN?
>> THERE'S FOUR REFERRALS HERE,
I THINK THE ONE THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THE ONE THAT SAYS,
IT'S A CRIME TO SOME VERTE A
LAWFUL FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT.
AND THE LAWFUL FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT IS WHERE ACCORDING
TO THE 12 AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SENATE, WHEN THIS CASE VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, OVERSEAS THE
COUNTING OF THE VOTES.
AND I THINK THE PART OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT IS MOST
SIGNIFICANT, LEGALLY AND
REPREHENSIBLE, IS WHEN TRUMP
WAS PRESSURING PANTS.
HERE'S TRUMP, THE BOSS, THE
SUBORDINATE AND HE SAY, YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE MY FRIEND.
YOU'RE A LAMP, YOU'RE BETRAYING
US.
AND THAT'S A NORMAL CASE WITH
THE BOSS PUTTING KIND OF
PRESSURE ON A SUBORDINATE IT'S
ALMOST A CRIME IN ITSELF.
>> OF COURSE WHEN YOU PROVE ONE
OF THESE, THEY EACH COME WITH
MULTIPLE YEARS SENTENCES.
BUT ANYTHING WOULD BE HUGELY
SIGNIFICANT.
JUST A STATE THE OBVIOUS.
>> YES, BUT I THINK THAT PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO START THIS OUT
JUST LIKE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT'S NOT
IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE ONE,
AND QUITE FRANKLY I THINK IT
WILL RESONATE.
AND IT DOES RESONATE WITH
PEOPLE.
WHAT'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TALKING TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT GONNA BE YOUR FRIEND,
WE JOKED THAT IT'S AS IF TRUMP
WAS SAYING, TO PANTS, NEXT YEAR
I'M NOT GONNA INVITE YOU TO MY
BIRTHDAY PARTY AT MAR-A-LAGO.
>> PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
PRESSURE, IT MAKES SENSE, TO
YOUR POINT IF YOU'RE GONNA
COLLIDE WITH CHARGES TO GO WITH
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND.
IN PART --
AGAINST THE PUBLIC.
CARL, JOHN EASTMAN, THE LAWYER
ALONG WITH DONALD J TRUMP
ISSUED THE --
OBSTRUCTION FOR OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING AND CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES.
PRESUMABLY, ALSO FOR THE
INSURRECTION AND CONSPIRACY
CHARGES.
HE'S JUST RESPONDED SAYING,
IT'S YET ANOTHER PARTISAN AND
POLITICAL STUNT.
THAT'S THE FIRST RESPONSE THAT
WE HAVE.
>> AND THE EXPECTED.
HE IS A PRINCIPAL CONSPIRATOR.
AND WHAT TODAY WAS OUTLINED AS
A ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES, TO PREVENT
REELECTION OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THE TRANSFER OF POWER.
BUT WE STARTED A SMALL TALK OF
HISTORY, ONE OF THINGS WE'VE
BEEN ASKING, IS THERE ANOTHER
JOHN DEAN.
SOMEBODY WHO CAN BRING THE
HOUSE DOWN.
THE ANSWER IS POTENTIALLY, YES.
WE GOT A HINT OF IT TODAY.
PAT CIPOLLONE.
HE'S THE COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHO IN THE HEARINGS WE CAN SEE
HIM, HAM AND HA, AS HE TOOK
PRIVILEGES.
HOWEVER, HE KNOWS EVERYTHING.
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING.
THERE IS INDICATIONS THAT HE'S
COOPERATING WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THOSE PRIVILEGES MIGHT NOT
APPLY.
I THINK WE BETTER KEEP OUR EYE
ON THAT, SUBSTANTIALLY, BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY SIGNIFICANT.
>> I'LL JUST LEAVE US ON THAT.
TO SAY THE COMMITTEE BELIEVES
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, PAT
CIPOLLONE,